hello everyone welcome to a video on
code Tecna toriel's today I want to talk
a little bit about return values and
function values in C++ and just give a
little overview of how they all works
the options you have so we're an open
visual studio 2019 create a new project
let's just leave it empty we're just
doing C++ here but I don't see plus plus
and I'm going to call this I guess just
return values that's fine
okay create it and we're just gonna get
a plain old C++ project set up that
compiles with visual studio compiler
first C++ and first of all I'm going to
change this to show all files show all
files and there's no files in here so we
have an empty project as we intended
we're gonna not put this Hamill even in
debug and X we'll put in the next 64 I
guess it doesn't really matter whole
life for our case and where it adds up
C++ files and new item and sure we'll
just make a well we want to main it just
defaults the source on this so I'm just
gonna put a main in this source file and
it'll figure it out that's just hello
world this so we should just get a hello
world and that popped up so fast that we
couldn't tell so all we can do if we
wanted to stop is go just care and then
C and standard C in that care way it'll
stop us at this prompt there we go
so we just need to hit enter basically
before you enter a key and press enter
so that'll stop us at the end okay so
return values when you want to get
something back from a function or you
want a function to modify a current
variable it's often when you want a
return value let's say you're making a
game and you have a function called
damage do damage and on this we want a
float of an amount of damage and we want
a target so the target will be for now
we'll call it a actual target okay so
now he needs to know what target is and
we'll just say struct target and it has
double HP or hit points let's make it a
float actually we'll say it starts out
with 100 hit points just by default yeah
so if you don't specify it'll have a
hundred and this do damage function
we'll go ahead and define it up here it
just takes this target in there hit
points and it's gonna - it by the amount
of damage takes whatever is on the left
side and - is it by whatever is on the
right side so it'll actually modify this
value so the problem here is this target
will probably come in as a copy unless
we put a reference symbol here and I say
probably because you kind of have to in
C++ because every compiler can do
something different you're on the same
compiler as me I can tell you what will
happen but if you're on a different one
I cannot tell you what will happen
especially if you're on an older one
much older one okay so what we want to
do here is pull it in by reference that
way it tells C++ to pull it in by
reference and it's an actual reference
to the actual variable and
we can access that actual target the
real thing not a copy and it's hit
points in subtracted by the mountain
damage amount of damage is also gonna
come in and say copy in this case that
is fine because we're not gonna modify
it however we can make it a little
faster if I pull it in by reference and
we're not modifying it so it's fine
right well let's just make sure this
never gets modified because we don't
want it to here to damage only does
damage it doesn't affect the amount of
damage so we make it a constant in that
way if in any case someone tried to
added this amount of damage that came in
my reference they'll get a compiler
error but in the meantime is faster
because it's pulling it in by reference
and not having to make a copy so let's
do a few things here to choose actions
so let's attack so we'll make a little
switch to handle this and we're gonna do
some damage we need to target so we're
gonna have to instantiate some stuff for
the game so let's make a target all
initial target it's gonna come in with a
hundred hit points because that's what
the default constructor will do how much
damage do we want to do it let's just
say we're gonna do 100 to this initial
target now some things will happen based
on this damage it's hard you may be
reduced below zero or it may not be so
we might want to spit out a message and
we couldn't do that right here in this
do damage or we could have it handled
somewhere else and leave or do damage
nice and pure because we know that this
works should work a hundred percent
perfect for subtracting that amount of
damage no matter what from the targets
hit points as long as this is not a copy
which it isn't going to be unless we
make a copy ourselves before calling it
maybe we need some sort of result so we
could check the initial targets
points afterwards so we could go
something like this
target died we could also spit out the
damage inflicted or something like that
we could we could what might be nice
here is actually to call a after hit
routine to like log the damage and spit
out any relevant messages after a damage
the animals say after damage so we could
take this in again this target this time
is going to be constable us we can't we
don't want to edit it in the after
damage triggers but we do need to know
about it so we can check it
so we'll basically take this code right
here paste it in I'm gonna get rid of
this and we can just call after damage
right here with the amount of damage and
the target so when this gets called and
the target becomes Const it's basically
going to do a Const cast to go from
mutable to unmute Abel
so the target will now be unmute in this
after damage and we want to do it that
way basically in case we have code were
writing every day maybe other people
working on it and we want to make sure
that the target never gets modified in
this function because we don't intend
that to be part of our workflow in
design so a lot of this stuff in code
they you will learn over time comes back
to design it's a I think it's better to
study a lot a lot of design before even
coding at all because if you know
exactly what you're doing things will
pop out to you when you come up come
upon them in code or in documentation
like oh yeah that I know where any that
the hard study soft study philosophy so
we want to say if it died and we want to
also do other things what else do we
want to do now the target here so we're
trying now to just standard console out
the target console doesn't know how to
handle this because it's destruct but we
can tell it how to with operator nope
this does have to be a friend and there
we go and now when we do damage we
should get a note of the after damage we
should get an amount damage inflicted on
and once a target died if it died and
we'll just put this in a while loop so
that weekend and do it over and over
until we're done we use an int you know
let's see zero is going to be false
everything else is going to be true so
we'll start it out at one so we'll enter
zero to quit if we're running becomes
zero
it'll be false it'll be a quit it's
pretty standard for an integer so we
could just put another thing here like
99 is quit so then we'll just have this
if choice equals 99 running equals zero
that way this will make this false in
the next loop so we have a way to quit
and we no longer need this character
thing at the end let's go ahead and run
this let's see if it works as we expect
after damage identify are not found so
okay because of how we're declaring them
in the order this is the program's
actual injury point this is the first
thing it sees so at this point
it doesn't see after damage it doesn't
know what it is hasn't been defined yet
so let's move this above it above damage
and hit play again and there we go pops
up asks us for an action so we can
attack or quit let's go ahead and hit
and one enter an attack hundred
inflicted on bass actor choose actions
attack again hundred inflicted on bass
actor target died choose action okay so
it died that time it didn't die the
first time because we're checking up hit
points is less than zero and it was
exactly zero let's try to quit just make
sure that works quit all right it
actually quits out of there now that
we've ran it once we'll see some things
we want to clean up just say a target
only member functions and bases can be
virtual so because this is a friend
it can't be virtual so that's something
how do you make a virtual Ostrom
operator looks like someone has asked
this before it's a pretty old question
but it is really quite relevant to what
we're doing okay looks like we need to
make it Const
that's the big thing and not a friend
and it looks like we can't take in the
target which makes sense because since
it's now not a friend in but rather a
member of the class the target is itself
okay now this doesn't like this spitting
out target and so let's how see how when
you're supposed to use it now it has the
O string part oh wait is saying that's
really weird seems backwards okay so we
have to put let's see if I've got this
right
we'll have to go Target spin out
standard see out and then a new line at
the end okay this feels really awkward
to me I don't think I've ever done it in
this order before so but it does seem to
compile let's go ahead and do an attack
and now the target does die and we did
inflict the hundred damage okay very
good
so we're going to quit there
well let's recap okay so we learned that
well this is the return value we learned
a lot of stuff I talked about a lot of
stuff but the main thing I wanted to get
into and I just kind of over explained
other things while I was at it is the
return values and really the point is
you can rather than processing a return
value from this side you can have this
do some other thing and what you want to
modify you can pass in as a reference
that way your function has access to it
you have to be very careful with these
sorts of functions because they are
literally modifying data from the rest
of your code base so you have to be sure
what they're doing isn't going to mess
something else up and that's why we're
starting with a really simple case there
are some overflow problems here you
could do so much damage that the targets
hit points go out of the range so there
is those sort of concerns
but we didn't address that here and I
don't think there's really need to in a
simple demo case but you should be aware
of overflowing variables because it does
crash programs there are ways around
that always you just have to code it up
correctly and think about large numbers
ahead of time so we're allowed to modify
this target and that essentially is a
return value because we're while we're
not directly saying return it we are
taking some known thing and modifying it
as the same we can do by returning the
results and modifying it in code the
references have to be actual things if
they don't exist the code is gonna have
an error and do all sorts of weird stuff
so it might be a good option to pass
this in by pointer you pass it in by
pointer is it a copy of the pointer so
if a pointer is passed to a function as
a parameter and tried to be modified
then the changes made to the pointer do
not reflect back outside the function
this is because only a copy of the
pointer is passed to the function it can
be said that pass by pointer is passing
a pointer by value in most cases this
does not pretend a problem but the
problem comes around when you modify the
pointer inside the function instead of
modifying the variable you're only
modifying a copy of the pointer and the
original pointer remains unmodified okay
so yeah it actually would work because
you're still pointing to the same data
and you can also check for null in these
cases so let's do that instead in here
when we're passing in again we're gonna
do it as a because of contr which will
still make another copy but at least we
know it can't be modified so the
compiler could optimize more if it
wanted to I think we have to dereference
this and there we go we can now check
for null if we want to and
your target we could make it a pointer
no then we also have to allocate it we
could even just do it like this and
leave it uninitialized
and that would be it it would pass in
here as null and the problem with that
is when we do this do damage function
this could all be null so we actually
want to have a null here check here if
and to do that we'll have to say if no
target basically if not target because
this would be just like this is if it
exists which it's anything but null this
will come back true but if we want to
say it's false go into this loop we have
to put a knot symbol I know that's
confusing but this is the same as if
target equals equals null null pointer I
can see the advantage of the readability
of target equals equals the null pointer
so we're gonna leave it the more
readable one know for now since this is
more of a demo so now if the target is
null we could just not do the damage and
we could just return it might be nice to
spit out a message target is null and
let's just go ahead and run it with null
and it still complains it won't actually
let us compile uninitialized local
variable fine we'll initialize it and
there we go it still works the same
so we now want to return value and let's
make this an integer so now we can take
advantage of this rather than it being
void we can now have this return an
actual thing it might actually make
sense to be some sort of damage results
yeah let's say this damage results and
then we'll make a struct so if you want
to if you want to return something
specific something that's not just an
integer or a float but has multiple
values you can make it as struct so we
can make a struct here and call it
damage results damage results we'll have
them both handle it
so after damage is going to return the
final one so what we'll need to do here
is we'll need to make the variable so
we'll make damage results right here
instantiate it and we'll just call the
results and now we're gonna make this
equal to whatever after damage returns
and then we're gonna return it
optionally rather than worrying about
all this we can just okay then we're
gonna return it so there's three lines
there it's complaining probably because
damage results hasn't been defined
incomplete type right so we can do that
and make it a complete type just defined
as nothing but maybe we want to have a
string in here no we'll have an e num in
here this could be weird but we'll say
alive dead I'm just dead and alive is
fine for now
together dead or alive so target status
can be dead or alive now later we might
want other things in here like like
searching you know depending on AI
sleeping but right now we're just gonna
do dead and alive
in this way we can just populate all
this here with what we want to say we'll
just work up these and these logs a
little bit rather than doing so many
CEOs okay so I want to do target status
equals dead it doesn't know what that is
so we have to dig in a little here and
we're expecting it to return from after
damage so let's instantiate it in here
and we'll just return it entirely so it
will return the result of after damage
so we got to null check we have it
actually do the damage and then we have
it return the results of the damage Khan
doesn't see this dead here because we
need to preface it represent with target
status and it still doesn't see it
because it's within damage results
struck like that since it's public we
can still see it but to get to it we
have to scoped to it twice so it's a
little weird because of that but other
than that it's fine of course target
status comes from results dot target
status so it's the one we instantiated
we don't have it set to a default
I think it'll default to dead so we'll
set our result log to be whatever this
message would be basically and we can do
that with a string we can basically set
this amount of damage to a string to
string amount of damage we need to
include string well we need results dot
result log
so we're actually accessing this
variable here seems to fine then we can
just append you just do this same thing
do it plus equals and we'll do put
damage and flicked it on which is this
is a Const care but it should be able to
handle that and then we just want this
target name yeah we don't really need
this oh stream thing anymore we would
have to declare a string stream to get
this out so it's a little awkward at
this point so maybe we just want
something like and ER and we'll just
have a string handle it just for
simplicity sake and we'll just call it
name mol default name is a target and
now what we can do is we can just see
out the name here but if we're not using
the see how thing we can just get the
name since it's public here on the
target pin in that case we'll just add
that to the results log the name of it
results result log plus equals the
target name and absolutely reference
since it's that pointer we've already
done the check for null pointer by the
time a call after damaged so we know
that it's target's not null okay so that
this should work I think we're just
gonna want maybe a new line no we don't
want even new lines well let the user
handling the results log deal with new
lines will just populate them one at a
time any time they do damage okay so now
after damage rather than speed out
messages we get a results log of damage
results so we do damage here
and we got to do something with a
results log
so this do damage is gonna end up
returning one we're gonna need one
results damage results so we'll declare
one right here and then we'll just set
it equal to whatever this do damage does
whatever it returns so that'll run the
function get them for a hundred on the
on the initial target bringing the
results so what we can do here is we can
now process results and we could do it a
whole lot in line here since damage
results is a struct we have to check
specific things on it
however we could just look at this
target status so we could switch on
damage results target status and then we
have some different cases we have now
this is going to be weird cuz these are
long damage results damage target status
dead break ultimately we probably want
to spit out this message the results log
I'm going to rename this control RR it's
a very nice refactoring tool in visual
studio to double click on something
control RR and then rename it to like
message yeah I like message better
so in any case here we're gonna spit out
the message and that is damage results
dot message die spelled wrong there we
go and we know we need a new line here
so that way if we end up moving this all
into a class of its own
we don't want to have to include C out
in that class will have that only if
needed in the stand she ation okay so
now we do it a couple different things
we could say hey okay so if the target
died we'll say writing equals zero I'll
just quit the program this the only only
thing there otherwise we'll leave it the
same do nothing so I really don't need
this break here because the default also
does nothing but whatever it doesn't
doesn't matter that kind of the point of
this is to show you the switch statement
ideally you would probably have a
function here like process results and
pass in the results by Const reference
and then do all the switch state and
stuff so let's just do that process
damage results that way the point is
kind of to make our instantiation code
as simple as possible and this
behind-the-scenes code do all the
complicated long-winded stuff so let's
grab all that and what we're gonna pass
in here is damage results let's go ahead
and make this function process damage
results this one might be more specific
to our game state because our game state
is going to do
all the handling of when we quit and
stuff so maybe this returns okay yeah so
we find I think this void we need damage
results here we don't want to edit this
damaged results here so we're making a
conference dmg results I don't know I
haven't really thought this through what
to do what these dead and alive cases
ultimately we want to destroy the target
or whatever have the target drop its
stuff so maybe drop stuff is is what we
would want to do here but for now I'm
just gonna do nothing and we just spit
out the message really so I think that's
all we're gonna do in this case and
rather than doing all this make
instantiate and results and then pass it
in we could just take since this returns
the damaged results we could just put it
right there and simplify that a little
bit so now we have kind of a cascade of
functions going on based on our return
values since this one returns what
process damage result once it works
let's go ahead and hit play just give it
a little one last run looks like we have
a function error here okay after damage
needs to return a value we weren't
actually returning up tune to this so
that's our problem return results that
way the do damage can return it because
after damage returns it to do damage
which is calling it right here at the
end it's going it play it's complaining
about something oh I'm not returning
anything here I guess we could return
oh this is actually somewhat tricky
because this is expecting this actual
damage results to process so we can't
just return nothing we need to return
something if we're going to return we
could just we never want to pass in an
old target forever doing that we're
doing something wrong in our code so
let's just call an exit right here after
spinning out the target as an old
message and maybe we can stop the exit
pipe right here with just this little
cin hack that way we make sure that the
user sees this target as an old message
so we'll do it that way
and looks like we're missing a bracket
somewhere do I have to have breaks in
here time is a bracket up here somewhere
I guess you need breaks you have to have
at least one break and your switch I'm
guessing I didn't realize that I guess
I've just always had a break until that
final case there all right choose action
let's do an attack and we get our new
message log it no longer says that they
died though because it handles that with
processed damage results and all does
this spit out this message so we
actually did update this message the
target died I think so let's take this
after damage where we have their status
and let's make a little hip statement
here if we basically want this results -
we're doing it equals equals check
though if they're dead we'll say the
hold is add it to the message okay
doesn't get complicated real fast
period and then we want their name again
and then we want then died okay so now
that should give us a better message
when we attack and kill something there
we go now pins any target died or
whatever its name is thousand damage
inflicted on no this is the name of a
target and then it would say whatever
its name died if he died so our message
is a little better there and it's also
modular enough to handle a lot of
different potential cases that we could
build up over time in our little little
game thingy so there's nothing else to
do just keep saying it died because we
don't have any way to destroy it or
anything like that yet which is maybe
what we should start building next if
we're gonna continue this but for sake
of example I think I've shown enough
about turn values and the basics of
getting some little
system going in C++ another important
thing we want to do here since we're
manually handling our memory just before
exiting Orwell will improve this later
the program is gonna exit anyway and
destroy the data so we don't necessarily
have to really care about deleting this
initial target thing right now because
it's gonna do so right here anyway but
if this were somewhere in the middle of
another system we need to make sure we
delete when we leave it otherwise it's
just gonna sit there or it could
potentially just sit there so it's kind
of good practice to get used to of
anytime you instantiate something with
this new you should have an Associated
delete somewhere now we could say
there's only one target allowed at a
time and it's this initial target and if
it dies we delete it
and Riaan Stan she ate it has a new
target so we could have some kind of
system like that for a single unique
enemy that keeps coming back or we'll
say an enemy slot rather that keeps
coming back like a spawn or something
you kill it it gets deleted then it
reads in Stan sheets with a new new
thing that would be a lot of playing
around with memory so there might
actually be a better way of doing it
anyway this has gone on long enough hope
you guys enjoyed this this live coding
session about return values where we
have made somewhat of a little game we
can do some damage to a target all right
all right well if you have any comments
leave them below they like the sort of
video be sure to leave a like and I'll
know that I should make more of these
sorts of videos and mat out peace out